Peterborough is an old city but as
laboratory for a very new politics
breakthrough parties on the earth old
ways of thinking political religions
being reformed and challenged by those
preaching a different gospel chief among
them the brexit party this is a seat
which voted 60% to leave in 2016 but
it's also a classic labor Tory marginal
swapping hands between the two since
1910 a breakthrough here would be a
major shock to the system yet they're
now the favorites I think it sends a
message to Parliament that the people
feel betrayed that the people don't
trust them anymore that they have failed
to deliver on one choice in the last
three years that they said they would
deliver on and I think it should send
strong concerns because I think it'll be
the crack in the door that will open to
a flood of brexit candidate
[Applause]
twenty years to get a parliamentary hold
this was a seat held by Labour with a
narrow 600 majority until their MP Fiona
honest Anja was recalled following a
perjury trial their new candidate Lisa
forms has likewise been mired in some
controversy over claims of anti-semitism
she declined us an interview though on
the ropes Labour's local organization is
strong you can't rule them out but you
can sense just how much of a bind the
party is in as in the locals and the
euros their vote fracturing for
different reasons in different
directions Labour Party can't seem to
decide which way they want to go just
Jeremy Corbyn doesn't seem like a very
good politician I think I think if
they've got off the fence about brexit I
think jeremy corbyn's handling a bridge
that has been at absolute shambles this
is a big problem labour unexpectedly
took the seat in 2017 by bringing the
remain vote together
the album the DeMars a snapping are
there he is look at the European
elections you know look our recent
success in the local elections here in
Peterborough you see that more and more
people are seen that's the key issue of
the day and those the kind of options we
have we're saying let's have a second
referendum let's have the opportunity to
say the the deal we have now within the
European Union is the best deal for
Britain but they're not the only ones
snapping the Greens are hopeful to think
the tea party deadlock has been broken
this year and I think this could
potentially be the start of that I hope
it is and I hope the Green Party
continues to make strong inroads what
was striking in Peterborough is that
fairly anyone mentioned the Tories it's
as if the brexit party wasn't only the
party of levers but of the
right-of-center to the Conservatives
light labour declined us an interview
but one of their leadership hopefuls was
around to do what he could whilst I'm
watching in showing how difficult it
will be to keep the Tory tribe
appropriately enough Catherine of Aragon
Henry the eighth's first wife is buried
here
she was a casualty of this country's
first break with Rome it's possible that
the two-party system and the
unprecedented strain will likewise be a
victim of our second Lewis could all Sky
News Peterborough
you